(upbeat music)
- Welcome to A Conversation with History.
I'm Harry Kreisler
of the Institute of International Studies.
Our guest today is Sir Lawrence Freedman
who is Professor Emeritus of War Studies
at King's College in London.
He is a prolific writer
of articles and books
on issues of security
including nuclear deterrents,
matters of war and peace.
He has many publications.
Some of his books include
Nuclear Deterrents, Strategy: A History,
and his most recent book
is the Future of War: A History.
Sir Lawrence, welcome to Berkeley.
- Good to be here.
- Where were you born and raised?
- I was born in the northeast of England,
a place called Whitley Bay,
which is close to Newcastle
and I stayed there until I
went to university at 18.
I've never really been back.
- And looking back,
how did your parents shape
your thinking about the world?
- I mean, my father was,
had a shop,
was not particularly
successful at business,
but he'd been a commissioned
officer during the war.
He was in the Fleet Air Arm,
he joined in 38.
He ended up Lieutenant Commander,
so that was very important to me.
It was important to him.
So the sort of the shadow
of the second world war
was very important.
Being Jewish was important
because where I was there
weren't very many Jews.
So it was, I had a sort
of sense of difference,
but as I went into my teens
became interested in the Holocaust
and started to find out more about it.
That was important.
But basically it was a not unusual
sort of lower middle class upbringing.
My parents were close.
I was influenced by my brother,
because neither of my parents
had been to university,
he was the first to go to university.
But there was nothing
particularly exceptional about it.
- Was there discussion at the dinner table
about war and issues of
current events and so on?
- Certainly a lot about current events,
particularly Sunday lunch.
My dad was working all
hours the rest of the time.
Sunday lunch was important for us,
when the family conversations took place.
And yeah, we were,
it was a particularly aware family.
My brother being a bit older than me
was very influenced by politics.
By the time I went to
university when I was 18,
I was very political, very determined.
This was the 60s, I was
very determined to be
very radical and change the world.
- And where did you do your undergraduate
and graduate work?
- So I went to Manchester
University in the northwest
of England,
did my undergraduate there.
(coughs)
Excuse me.
Then I went to York.
I did a Masters and actually
taught there for a year.
And I ended up at Oxford to do my
what they call a D.Phil., a PhD,
and finished it off there.
- And as you did your advanced studies,
was there one mentor or teacher
who was really influencing you greatly
in terms of the direction
your studies took?
- Yes.
By the time I got to Oxford,
I had a, I think, pretty
wide ranging education
and I had done sciences at high school,
so I moved into the social sciences.
I was interested in political
sociology, political theory.
And I moved into an
interest in military things
almost by accident
because I was interested
in the role of experts
and I'd chosen, because I
wasn't scared of the science,
I chose a nuclear scientist.
Then I ended up at
Oxford and Michael Howard
became my supervisor, and,
that was, and still is, in fact,
he's 95 now,
a very close relationship.
He was my mentor,
every move I made in the
earlier stages of my career
I would be consulting him.
But basically he was a role model.
When I found out he was
going to be my supervisor
I didn't know of him.
I went to buy a book of essays of his,
Studies of War and Peace.
I started reading them and I
didn't stop until I'd finished.
And I felt this is what I want to do.
I loved his ability to
capture great historical movements
in a matter of sentences
and his ability to synthesize,
his readiness to look at
disciplines outside history,
his policy engagement.
I just thought this was a
very complete sort of figure
and that shaped me a lot.
- I like to ask my guests
what they see as the skills
and temperament involved in what they do.
- Well it's an interesting, I mean,
you also have to be very careful
talking about your own skills.
I think what I've found,
given the stuff I'm dealing with,
which is in some cases very distressing,
often very controversial.
People have strong feelings about it,
say if you're dealing with
the Arab-Israeli Conflict
or nuclear weapons.
These are things people, quite rightly,
have very strong feelings about.
So to navigate one's way through this,
my basic approach has always been
to stay as close as
possible to the evidence.
And if the evidence tells me
what I want to think is wrong,
I have to accept that.
So I think the first principle is
get the best evidence you can.
And so I sort of think
of myself as a scavenger
for information.
You've got to keep on looking.
You've got some point you've got to stop
because otherwise you'll
never get anything written,
but I think that's the first principle.
The second is the onus's
own need to communicate.
I shouldn't eschew that
if I want to come up with new words
or use fancy language
that I'll keep my audience.
If I really want people to read me,
I've really got to work at that.
And again, that's something
I got from Michael Howard,
who's a brilliant stylist.
So I think,
I'm not in favor of over-egging it.
I don't think good
writing has to be flowery.
I think good writing can be
quite terse, short sentences.
So I think that side of
things is very important.
Third thing, I think,
is you've got to be prepared to be wrong,
you've got to be able to take risks,
try out an argument,
but I've never been of the
view that I'm infallible.
Looking back,
both personal and academic,
whatever detriments I've made
that I might make differently later on,
it's quite important to note
that I've spent a lot of
my time in administration
and management while also
trying to write books
and I always found that
if you can lead,
I think people have to
be prepared to lead,
but it makes leadership easier
if people know that if they argue with you
and talk to you, you might can be changed,
so I've always tried to
keep an open mind as well.
- What about temperament?
Patience must be very
important as, for example,
your beautiful book on strategy.
That's really a complex project
requiring a lot of patience
and looking at a lot of sources.
- I didn't think of it that way.
I'm not impatient,
but I wouldn't consider
myself most patient of people.
I think the thing is once
I'm into a piece of writing,
a piece of research,
it is almost like going into
a completely different mood,
become a different sort of person.
My wife refers to it as my writing daze.
So I sort of get into a place where,
I find it exhilarating.
I've never written on the basis
of ordering all my material
and then meticulously working through it.
I'm always playing with it, changing it,
and finding a new reference, exploring it,
which of course is much
easier to do these days
than it was when I started.
So I don't find, I don't
think of it as being patient,
and indeed,
with most of the books I've written,
I'm incredibly reluctant
to stop fiddling with them
even when we're into proof stage
and the publisher's are going crazy
with the changes I want to make.
I sort of see it as a constant
discussion with myself
to try to find out what's going on,
why this is an interesting topic,
how the argument can be developed.
- And what is the key to creativity?
Is it a kind of a flexibility
which you identify when
you're talking about strategy
as a way to be able to
respond to surprises
in what you're discovering as you research
and think about what you're researching?
- Yes, I mean, I've
always been very eclectic.
I suppose this is something
also about my approach,
and again, from Michael Howard.
I've always been instinctively
interdisciplinary.
I've never, I started off
I suppose identifying as
a political scientist.
Actually I would have said
a political sociologist
after my undergraduate times,
and then I sort of became
more of a historian
and known as a historian.
But I always thought of
myself as a bit of a hybrid.
And part of the fun is
seeing how other people
approach topics.
So for example when I did
the book on deterrents,
I read quite a bit of criminology
because they deal with deterrents
and the comparing how they address,
criminologists address the issue
gave me some ideas about how people in
security studies might address the issue
and doing strategy was even more of that,
social psychology and economics and so on,
and it's intellectually
challenging and that's good,
but I think it also gives you
a chance to see things
through different eyes,
and this is obviously
different from a lot of people
in my field because they
worry much more about
the disciplinary boundaries
and advancing the discipline,
and I'm actually not really interested
in advancing the discipline.
I've never seen that as
what I'm trying to do.
I don't think what I'm doing is science.
I think it's systematic, I hope,
and rigorous and evidence-based,
but I don't want to make great claims
for what I'm doing as
developing a discipline
that others will follow or
build on what I've done.
I've always seen it as setting myself
some perplexing problems
and try to find out the best answers.
- Your strategy book and your new war book
both have a subtitle of A History.
And history is very important for you.
What does working as a historian provide
in furthering your insight?
This is not true, obviously,
or at least I think it's not true,
political science and security
studies in the United States.
- Yeah, I'm very careful to say a history,
it's not the history,
partly because the history would be
beyond an individual,
so I would, a history is
to make clear it's my take,
and reflect my familiarity with
U.K. and American materials
I can move into other countries
but I don't feel as comfortable there.
Careful not to overstate
the range of what I'm doing.
I think history is the core
discipline for politics.
Maybe political scientists
don't always follow it,
but that's their mistake.
The idea that you can take something from
Asia in the 21st century
and then something from North
America in the 20th century
and something from Europe
in the 19th century
and code them and do a regression analysis
and believe you're saying
you've got a generalization
about national politics,
I just don't accept.
I think it's a specious sort of science.
And that's actually
not produced very much.
It tells us more than we could work up
by what's often derisively
called intuition.
I think we could work it,
you can know a lot about
international history
and have the sense of possibility
that it doesn't require you to go through
all that sort of business.
The value of history is
it gives you chronology,
it reminds you that when
one thing was happening,
other things were happening
that may well have impinged on it.
It tells you that what happened before,
how that's shaped,
and if you're interested in, as I am,
particularly in the history of ideas,
these ideas come from places,
and often what's interesting
is how concepts and ideas
develop in one setting
and move into another setting,
and it's the changes that are interesting.
So this is not to say
you can't do comparisons
or case studies, and so of course,
all of those things are helpful,
but history always gives
the context and sequence.
You read a lot of stuff where people
have just lost any sense of chronology
and therefore the
comparisons they're making
are invalid for that reason.
- What does this tell us
about theory and practice
basically, that, and here I mean,
that the ideas affect what we do with
unintended consequences, really?
- Yes and I think that's one reason why
the theorists or academics
should be humble in this.
We're not accountable except to our peers
and there's this enormous
pressure these days
to have impact and to be engaged
and in my time I've done plenty of that,
so I'm not, by no means
opposed to engagement with practitioners.
It is always important to have a good feel
for the constraint under
which they're operating
and one of the points I'll
make to younger scholars
if they're interested
in policy engagement,
is remember that this is a two-way thing.
The great advantage of
working with practitioners
is that you learn from them,
not only you pick up what's on their mind,
bits and pieces of important
information and so,
but you understand the
way the system works.
This is infallible people working
in imperfect organizations
with no time or under an
awful lot of pressure.
And the pressures are
often quite eccentric.
So unless you've got,
you know, even that seems
to me an important insight
that can then influence the way you work,
and most of my work, looking back,
is about policy making,
one way or the other,
it's about how decisions are made
and how choices are made.
- But you don't write it to
influence policy, really,
you're focused on the wonder
of understanding the context.
- I think it's important,
I never, I wouldn't write a book
with the aim of producing
lots of policy recommendations
at the end.
Apart from anything else,
and I've seen this happen numerous times,
you know, this sort of
endless academic cycle
of a problem, a call for proposals,
the grants are handed out,
the researchers are recruited,
the work is done,
by the time it all comes out,
the policy debaters moved on anyway.
So I don't see myself as
driven by policy agenda,
and I think academics
should feel perfectly free
to write something
because it's interesting
and it advances scholarship,
I think that's what we do.
When I've got involved in policy debate,
I find it's often most
useful in providing context,
why we've got this problem now,
what's the origins of that problem,
but also conceptually.
People keep on talking about deterrents
as a concept that was
developed during the Cold War
particularly, but not solely associated
with nuclear weapons
and is then transferable
to almost any given
security problem.
It's an interesting question to ask
and unpacking the concept
can give you clues
as to where it might be
relevant and where not.
Those are the useful things
I think academics can do.
What do we do about Korea?
What's the next step with Iran?
I have views on these, I can make my case.
I may know quite a bit about the issues.
But I wouldn't want to
overstate my views compared with
somebody who's bang in the middle
of the actual policy making.
- And in addition to history,
one senses this comparative
drawing on other fields
and insights, for example,
at the end of the book on strategy,
you emphasize that, or you
propose a kind of working notion
of thinking of strategy
as a script, really.
- Yeah so that came from social psychology
and I certainly wasn't the
first in the field to do that.
I mean, a number of other
people have picked up on
this idea before.
So I thought to emphasize my originality,
I was derivative there,
but I tried to make a bit more of it.
And so part of it was this idea of script
which is sort of the mental
template that you have,
that you recognize a situation
and something in your head
tells you it's that situation
and this is what you might expect next,
and then you realize
actually there's differences
from your expectations so
you develop improvisations
as you go along.
Then what we've found having done that
was to look at how people
also think of scripts
which is from plays and drama,
which led to a comparison between
the control the dramatist
has over the plot
and the strategist who
doesn't have control,
which becomes a way of making a point,
of stressing what, which was to me
the most important thing about strategy,
that it is about adaption and flexibility
and improvisation, and it's not a plan.
It doesn't follow a sequence of steps
to a definite destination.
So I just find it very suggestive
to draw on these other approaches,
but I turn it into something of my own.
A long time ago when I was at York,
and in those days there
were these big debates,
still going on,
about whether there are
paradigms in political theory,
social theory, that you're a Marxist,
or you're an idealist or
you're a realist or whatever,
but I thought this was pretty artificial.
I remember one of my
colleagues at one point sort of
saying, almost in exasperation,
"Well tell me at what point
does mindless eclecticism
"become creative synthesis?"
(laughs)
And I always thought that
was a great question.
- I get also the sense that you are
how do I want to say?
The hidden elephant in the room is that
you are a student of
human nature actually,
and because as you write
the complexity of humans,
willfulness, folly, hubris, stupidity,
intelligence, creativity, solidarity,
the human dimensions of
war are really striking
as you become unconventional
when you look at
what actually happens in war.
- The interesting thing about
war as a topic for study.
It's a very grim topic.
But it also shows human
nature at its extremes.
So it brings out the worst
and can bring out the best.
And often in the same person.
So that's what makes it
particularly interesting.
It always used to be my argument
as to why we had a department
of war studies at King's
was this is a phenomenon
that illuminates so much else
about humanity.
Also I think it's important to maintain
the sense of what you're talking about
are human beings in stressful situations.
Again going back to political
science approaches to war,
it can become rather dehumanized.
How do you round up
deaths to a round number?
How do you show whether
you've counted accurately?
How do you capture the aftermath of war,
which is often full of
famine and economic distress?
So the indirect effects of war
can be as severe as the direct.
So if you're not prepared to
address that and cope with that
then it becomes a very dehumanized topic
and you can see why
people do it sometimes,
because you can be overwhelmed
by the numbers, which is why,
a particular story from
the Holocaust can be,
touch you far more than talking about
the overall statistics
of the numbers killed,
and it's actually one reason
why I think warfare now,
the sort we've been involved in recently
often involves, at least for
the Americans and the Brits,
individual, personalized
deaths that you can
look at the pictures of the individuals
and think what's been
lost and what they did
rather than just, we lost 10,000 today.
So I think if you lose that,
you don't understand
what's going on properly,
but also you forget why the topic matters.
- Ideas are important to you
and ideas have also been important
in understanding how we
explain the structural conditions
that might lead to war,
and so if we look at today, environment,
one concept that's there is the idea
of the rise and fall of great power.
Talk a little about that idea
and whether it helps us understand
what's going on in the world
with America in decline
and China rising.
- It's a really interesting topic because
it's an issue that never quite goes away.
So when I started
really getting interested in this stuff,
which was 72,
that's when I started my PhD,
the talk then was of the
decline of the United States,
Vietnam and then into Watergate and so on
compared with the rise
of the Soviet Union,
big military build up which was going on.
And then in the late 80s
it was the US that was overstretched
and Japan and Germany
surging forward economically.
And now it's United States in decline
and China moving forward, so,
and getting the measure of the Chinese
is an important part of understanding
what's going on to the US.
One response to that is to say,
"Well we've been here before
"and it didn't quite
turn out as expected."
The United States kept on going
and these other countries
fell by the wayside,
Soviet Union eventually imploded,
Japan went into years of stagnation,
so who knows what will happen with China.
That can be misleading, this
time it may be different.
And then you get the question
of historical parallels.
So Gray Mallerson produced this book on,
what was it, 16 cases of transition from
one great power to another
and normally this leads to war.
I think it's, I mean I don't
agree with the analysis.
I'm not sure these cases tell us
as much as he thinks they do,
but it's still an
interesting issue to raise.
Is there something about
this transitional period?
Kori Schake has just
produced a lovely book about
the transition from the UK
and Germany to US and Germany,
which was peaceful,
and that allows it to look
at some quite important issues,
not just about the structures
of international politics
and power but values and
similarities between the societies.
So I think that as with
all of these things,
there's an interesting question there,
there are comparisons to be made,
but it's only the starting point.
What's very dangerous is to
start reasoning by analogy,
because this happened, then
this time it's also gonna happen
The advantage of making
these comparisons over time
is to ask what's different,
not why this is bound to be the same.
- It's rich in insight but not necessarily
a foundation for prediction.
- Not a foundation for
prediction, certainly.
In some cases, people aren't really
even making comparisons.
Some people talk about
appeasement or Munich or so,
and it's just a short out
for we don't trust foreigners
and they'll get one
over on us or something,
it's not even serious
comparative research,
and work has been done on
July 14 or Munich or
Vietnam as being shorthands
for things you've got to be careful about
rather than the basis for serious
and for analytical comparisons.
But when you do look at,
you can start to have
a view about causation,
about what can really make
a difference in situations.
To take one example,
it was clear for whatever reason,
not just the railroads,
other decisions in July,
August 1914 were rushed.
People felt that they had to move quickly.
That had enormous influence on ways people
thought about crisis management afterward.
How do you buy time?
How do you get a chance
to look at your options?
So then you can look at Kennedy in Cuba.
In today's age of social media,
would he have been able not
to say anything in public
for so many days while
he worked out what to do?
Because we know if he had to
make an immediate decision
it would have probably
been much more military.
The work, Tom Schelling's,
I did on nuclear strategy
was all about his concern, all about,
a lot of it was about,
whether the pressure to preempt.
And so you've got a theme there
that you can follow all the way through
about crisis stability and preemption,
where you can look at these cases,
and you can learn from them,
they can be suggestive as
to risks that you might face
in the future.
So although every episode
is special in particular
and peculiar, often,
it doesn't mean to say
you can't be looking back
to comparable episodes
to alert you to possibilities
that you might otherwise miss.
- In the first section
of your book on war,
you focus on the German
victory over the French in 1870
and it is a case where the
interpretation of that by the actors
and the people who wrote
about it was wooden
and not nuanced in the way
that you were just describing
of how we draw ideas from the patterns,
by understanding the history.
Talk a little about that,
because the notion was decisive victory
meant on the one hand
that you could still win a war that way
but on the other hand,
people then used that
as an occasion for fear
about the lack of preparation
least they attack again.
- Yeah so, the more I looked at Sedan
the more fascinating it became a sort of,
well we now call it an
inflection point, I suppose,
not least because it completed
the unification of Germany.
- This is the Battle of Sedan in 1870.
- September 1870.
So it was a classic ideal type battle.
Started in the morning,
ended in the evening.
It was clear who'd won at the end.
The French army had been badly defeated.
And the normal assumption
from going back a long way
was that if you won a battle in that way,
you'd won the war, and politics followed.
And of course that's
not quite what happened,
because the French people
didn't accept the result.
Napoleon was out, Napoleon third was out
and a republic called
and an irregular conflict began.
So the interesting question,
one interesting question
was what the German general
staff took from this.
And because von Moltke, who was
the architect of the victory
and who was undoubtedly one
of the great strategists
of the 19th century,
they were so in awe of his
legacy, so committed to it,
that they didn't want to lose faith
with the idea of the decisive battle.
It just became a much more
demanding military challenge
than it'd been before,
and even von Moltke
himself became skeptical
about the possibilities.
They pushed on.
So they weren't prepared
to abandon this hope.
Secondly the arguments about
what happened after the battle
with the French irregulars
meant that they became very sensitive
to how you made sure that
civilians didn't get involved
in the future.
So they took calculated action
in Belgium and elsewhere,
particularly in Belgium,
at the start of the first world war
to repress the local population
so that they accepted the result.
Third, these tactics adopted by
the Germans against the French people
after September 1870
were the matter of big
debate between von Moltke
and Bismarck,
and this debate was really important,
I mean Bismarck got his way,
but left a view which is
incredibly strong to this day
that politicians should not be allowed
to interfere in operational matters,
that the politicians could
decide who you were fighting,
where you were fighting,
why you were fighting,
what should be done with the victories
when they've been achieved,
but everything that went on in the middle
was a military responsibility,
which I think is untenable position,
but was nonetheless
one that you could see
very strictly adhered to
by the German general staff,
they couldn't share in December of 1914
the full implications of their plans.
They didn't subject themselves
to civilian interrogation
about what it all might mean,
and of course the famous
comment after the war
by Clemens, so the war is too important
to be left to the general,
reflected that strong view
that just letting the
military establishment
determine everything about how the war
was going to be fought could
just lead you into disaster,
which is not to say that
politicians by any means
get these things right,
but it's just that the
military prerogatives could be,
could lead to danger.
And you see that in this book
but I was, just been looking at
some of the debates of
the late 50s in the US
about nuclear strategy
and read Daniel Ellsberg's latest book
which is a very powerful description
of what had happened then.
You find the Anti-Strategic Air Command,
Curtis LeMay and Thomas Power,
both using this argument
that this has nothing to
do with the politicians,
even when you're talking
about nuclear strikes
that are gonna cause hundreds of millions,
literally hundreds of millions of deaths,
this is an operational matter,
not for the politicians.
So the strength of that
idea is very powerful.
- This is an interesting discussion
because what you're demonstrating is
your role as a historian
is to focus on the
context and implications
in a way, so as a theorist,
you're able to go back and see patterns
that the actors themselves
recognize different patterns
that in the long run turn
out to have consequences
for other actors which changes
the meaning of their insights
- Yes, I think that's true.
I think the,
if you look at this particular issue of
operational control, which leads,
you know, eventually to
the American military
to describing an operational
level of strategy,
which is basically an apolitical level,
where the politicians stay
out, no micromanaging.
- And this is actually the policy of
President Trump in Afghanistan,
turning it over to the people.
- And you know one of the dangers is
it allows politicians to
abandon their responsibilities
because, again, we've seen this in the UK
with Iraq and Afghanistan,
is, well you know I took military advice
and you wouldn't want me to
question military advice,
and I followed it.
Well no, actually you should
question military advice,
that's part of your job.
You may follow it in the end,
but you've certainly got to question it.
And you can see this,
again it's not in this particular book
but I did a couple of essays recently
on the development of
the idea of strategy,
well how did people actually define it
during the 19th century?
We had a very narrow military definition.
It was about battle,
tactics was about how you fought,
strategy was about how you got
into the position to fight.
And then policy was something else.
So we now think about strategy
as the interaction of policy
and military activity.
But this came quite,
and you can see the sort of stirrings
in the late 19th century,
early 20th century
as military theorists realized
that it's much harder to make the case
that they are solely in control,
they should solely be in control
of how forces are deployed
because they depend on the
politicians for the basis,
the budgets,
and so is it reasonable to
say that we've been let down
because you haven't given enough money
or you haven't secured
this bit of foreign land
in order for us to place ourselves
in preparation for a campaign,
and then say what happens thereafter
has nothing to do with you?
And so you can see them grappling with it.
But in the end,
the comfort zone is that
politicians should keep out.
I think that's completely
broken down over the last
couple of decades
where clearly the wars
that were being fought
were so political in
everything that was being done
that we've moved so far away from the idea
of the decisive battle
to a large number of
smaller scale encounters
which add up to something
that looks a lot different in the end.
You can argue for the strict separation,
but the ethos is still very much there.
- One of the sections of your book
looks at what fictional
writers were saying about war.
I sense that you're constantly asking
where do the ideas come from?
What are the ideas?
What motivates the people with the ideas?
What is their agenda beyond
what they're arguing about?
- Yeah I think fiction's,
especially on some of
these really big questions
of what war might look
like, very important.
And at different times they're have been
different fictional approaches to this.
The best example is probably H.G. Wells
who, incredibly prolific,
had a political agenda.
He was sort of Fabian socialist.
Great believer in world government.
He thought world government
would only happen when
states abandon nationalism,
and they'd only do that
when some horrible, great big enormous war
had shown them how dangerous this was.
So there's a book he wrote
called The World Set Free
which captures this idea,
the world would be set free from war.
It was published just
before the first world war,
which introduced the idea of atomic bombs.
Now he was pretty au fait
with the science of the time.
We know what he'd read
and we know who he modeled
key characters upon.
He didn't particularly describe accurately
what the bombers would be like
or how they would be constructed,
but you know, this was at
a time when a lot of people
were saying they could
never be constructed.
But we do know that in the early 1930s
Leo Szilard, who was the Hungarian
who had emigrated in order to escape,
anti-Semitism was then in London.
He later came to the
states and was the person
who was very influential
in persuading Einstein
to write to President Roosevelt
about an atomic bomb program,
led to the Manhattan Program.
Well we know that he'd
read, he'd met Wells,
he'd read The World Set
Free quite recently,
and when he was thinking
about the problems
and decided how a chain
reaction was possible,
it was the atomic bomb.
And so it's called the
atomic bomb because of Wells.
Wells' influence in other areas,
when tanks came along
during the first world war,
that bore very little
relationship that those,
the armored vehicles Wells had described
in a much earlier book,
but those who are worrying
about this question
still had Wells in mind,
so I think they are influential,
and it's one of the big
issues with his vision
was whether he was correct,
not in the sense that
we got world government,
but after the demonstration
of the power of atomic bombs,
we haven't had another nuclear war,
hopefully we never will.
But that's quite a long run
that we've been through already.
So you know, maybe there
was a kernel of truth
in what he was saying.
- A section of your book
looks at future wars,
the introduction of cyber, of robots,
conflict taking place in mega cities
and so this raises the
other important dimension
in addition to ideas and
where they're coming from
and that is the love
affair with technology,
that technology will change everything
with regard to the next war.
But it's really, history
tells us, well no it won't.
- Well it does but not to
the extent that people hope.
And not necessarily in
ways that they imagine.
So for a country like America
which would prefer capital intensive
to labor intensive wars, as it were,
technology's an enormous
attraction, it always has been
as a way of gaining some
sort of strategic advantage,
reducing dependence on man power,
or people power now,
because it's men and women.
So that's always been a part.
And there's a tendency, which
became very strong in the 50s
after a succession, if you
just think of the tank,
the aircraft, radar,
submarines, missiles,
then atomic bombs and hydrogen bombs,
that technology would keep
on throwing up new challenges
and so on.
What happened I think was,
the new technologies couldn't change
the basic logic of what we came to call
mutual assured destruction.
So it didn't make a lot of
difference in that sense.
It raised new questions and challenges
but it didn't really shift that.
Then there were the new
technologies associated with
the digital age,
which seemed to provide an alternative
to reliance on nuclear weapons.
And what I think we've seen here,
there's two points,
these do allow you to do
things you couldn't do before,
so you can't ignore that,
but the actual way they're employed
and what they're employed
in combination with
makes a difference.
For example, in fact, two examples.
One, the great advantage of
precision-guided munitions
was that it would enable you
to avoid civilian targets.
You could attack the center of a city
and you wouldn't hit
a hospital or a school
because you knew where the
hospital and the school was
and you were sufficiently confident
in your cruise missile or whatever
that it would work it's
way around the street map
and hit exactly what
it was supposed to hit.
And that's true if you want
to fight a war that way.
But if you decide that actually
really what you want to do
is to hit hospitals and schools,
it'll do that too.
It's a choice that you've now got
that you didn't have before.
And therefore, it doesn't
mandate a particular strategy.
I think we wanted to think
that these weapons mandated a strategy
that allowed you to spare non-competence
but it turns out, not necessarily, so.
Another example is the ease with which
a lot of the critical
enabling technologies
are now disseminated to anybody,
an individual who wants them.
So that, you know, the time
of the Gulf War in 1991,
there were a series of
resources that were space-based,
accurate imagery of where
forces were deployed,
speed of communications,
positioning, so you knew where you were,
you knew where other people were,
navigation,
all of these are now on your iPhone.
So things that really made a difference
to the ability of the American military
to catch the Iraqis completely by surprise
and completely outfight them
are now available to me.
Now I don't link them
with any firepower myself,
but others do.
Then of course, later on
you've got the social media side of it
and all of a sudden all series
of instruments are available
to whoever wants them,
and again, it doesn't mandate
a particular approach,
it doesn't make war less destructive.
It doesn't mean that in the end
people will fight with the
weaponry that they can find,
however crude and basic it is.
But it does create new
choices and new possibilities.
- But it also leads to
the wrong lessons learned
when you go into Iraq a second time
and don't deal with the consequences
of your quick victory.
- Yes but I think
there's obviously a number
of things going on in 2003
of which one was Rumsfeld's
determination to demonstrate
that in contrast to Colin Powell
who wanted half a million troops
to defeat Iraq in 1991,
Powell could do it with
a third of the number,
Rumsfeld could do it with
and he could.
But what I meant was
that they had no capacity
to deal with what followed.
It wasn't that Rumsfeld
hadn't thought about it
he just didn't want to have
anything to do with it.
And not being forced
to answer the question
are you sure you can avoid these issues?
It was a perfectly good argument
that you don't want to hang around,
you want to get out as soon as possible,
that eventually you'd be seen as occupiers
and be part of the problem,
to which the answer is
yes, that's what'll happen,
and you won't be able
to avoid that problem
by becoming occupiers and running away
because you won't be able to get away
because you won't have anything,
nobody to hand over power to,
and so it proved.
This is stuff that I dealt with a lot
as a member of the UK Iraq Inquiry
is that the issues are recognized,
they're somebody else's problem,
and no preparations are made,
hardly any preparations are made
for what may need to be done.
It's not a question of,
I mean there's always gonna
be a degree of improvisation,
but if you've got no capacity,
just don't have the numbers of troops,
you don't have the
administrators prepared,
you haven't thought about issues
as simple as curfews,
then don't be surprised when things
go very badly wrong and a lot of people,
Iraqi and American and
British lose their lives.
- One final question
requiring a brief answer.
What would you like
the different audiences
to get from your book
On the Future of War?
The public on the one hand,
the policy makers on the other.
- The only sort of message which is
maybe a bit late is be skeptical.
When people tell you this
is how it's gonna be,
say, "Are you sure?" and ask questions.
That's the basic message
for policy makers.
Message for academics
about the limits of quantification
but also in a way it can be useful,
it's not a wholly
anti-quant book, not really.
I think for the public,
what you want out of a book,
you want people to find it interesting,
to want to keep on turning the pages
and to discover things about the past
that they may not have known
and in the process to
make them skeptical too,
to ensure if you're working in this field
without pushing too hard
or being to pious about it,
you're hoping for a more
informed, more questioning public.
And if it helps a bit
towards that, that's great.
If they just find it
interesting, that's great too.
- Well Sir Lawrence,
on that note I want to thank you very much
for being our guest on
Conversations With History
and I think I will show your book,
The Future of War: A History
which, there's a lot more in it
than we were able to discuss
in this hour of conversation.
So thank you very much to our audience
for joining us for this
Conversation with History.
(electronic music)